there are absolutely no shortcuts it
takes time if I wasn't paid a lot of
money I would still do what I what I
what I what I do
there isn't enough hours in the day to
be able to do both extremely well there
is nobody on planet earth like you I set
pretty high goals for myself it takes an
element of defining the ultimate
destination then empowering people to
actually go let me apprentice you let me
show you how to become good at it I
didn't have a clue what I wanted to be
you've got to get comfortable with being
uncomfortable
but life is funny you know because you
get the money and you get the knowledge
but life has passed you by he's the CEO
of Deloitte & Touche he was named one of
Consulting Magazine's top 25 most
influential consultants he speaks
regularly with top-tier media as well as
premier conferences and business schools
he's Puneet Rennes gen and here are his
top ten rules for success well I think
there's no no substitute for hard work
none zero I was in India I talked to 200
of the newly hired individuals and this
is I can say this because I'm of Indian
heritage they always asked me when I go
to India so tell us the one or two
shortcuts to get to your point and I
always say there are no shortcuts you've
got to put in the time and so I think
the first takeaway is there absolutely
no shortcuts it takes time and it takes
a lot of hard work I mean I really
really enjoy what I do
I really do and I think you know a
number of you probably are interested in
consulting I think my only advice and I
hope that I'm a few years older than you
so I have the right to give you a little
bit of advice but my only advice is pick
something that you will thoroughly enjoy
whatever that may be and I think if you
do that you know you will to answer the
first individuals question you'll
probably survive in it and potentially
maybe you'll thrive in it I mean I
usually don't say this but you know if I
if I wasn't paid a lot of money I would
still do what I what I what I what I do
I hope you know some of our managing
partners don't see this program because
my units may get cut but
I would still do I would still do what
what I do you know I'm surprised on a
yearly basis as to what kind of money I
make I mean I just am absolutely
surprised I would do it for a tenth of
what I make so you know just find
something that you really enjoy and I
think you'll thrive I define success two
ways one what I do here at the firm the
impact that I create my clients the
impact that I create for the partnership
now the new role that I have the legacy
that I leave that is one way that I will
define success you know I'm not a great
cricketer I love cricket I wish I was as
good as such and something dual core I'm
not this is my life's work what I do
here is my life's work it will define me
and the second thing that will define me
is what my 11 year old son thinks of me
when he becomes a man these are the two
things that define success for me
and in that is a little bit of a
conundrum because I love what I do it is
as I said my life's work I love my son
more than I love myself
and there is a constant tug there isn't
enough hours in the day to be able to do
both extremely well and so that is my
challenge there is nobody on planet
earth like you and you are unique you
have unique gifts that nobody else has
so as as quickly as you can accept that
the happier you will be why try and be
somebody else and why worry about others
accepting you I am Who I am I'm proud of
the fact that I am this way
and besides I don't have a choice this
is who I am and so I am very accepting
of the fact that I come with and my wife
is very accepting of the fact that I
come up with a certain package and it's
taken me a while to get comfortable with
this is Who I am
and these were the gifts that were given
to me by my parents and I'm not trying
to be somebody else I'm me
and I'm happy about that so I would say
to you you're unique you have your own
gifts there's nobody else like you and
just get comfortable with that and that
will give you a sense of peace and
frankly tremendous confidence because
you're not trying to please somebody
else you're trying to please yourself
now it's easier said than done because
we're trained from an early age to try
and please others I think that's a
losing battle because you ultimately end
up trying to be somebody else
and I say that about our firm as well I
mean I say in the u.s. that we aspire to
lead the profession we're not defined or
validated by comparing ourselves to
somebody else we don't care we don't
care what PwC does we don't care what
McKinsey does we don't care because
we're not going to be defined or
validated by comparing ourselves to them
we're unique we're special there's
nobody else like us so we're going to
define the profession in our image and I
think that applies to individuals as
well we're all unique and if you try and
be somebody else I think you'll be quite
unhappy I'm wondering if you have any
personal tricks on how you keep yourself
motivated I set a pretty high goals for
myself
they're usually higher than what I think
most other people said from upset for me
and I just am a I'm very driven to
achieve them I'm a goal-oriented
individual and and I just am very driven
to achieve those goals how do you
motivate people to get things done
you know I'm the reason why I paused was
I was trying not to come up with a with
a try to answer I I think and this is a
much used to an overused term I think
defining a overall goal that's that's
reaching in that it isn't easily
attainable and then empowering and this
is the overused word and then empowering
people to actually go try and and and
get it and ensuring that when they when
they have a misstep that you're there to
to help them long is it's probably the
way to I mean you know to be frank with
you most of the people that we hired the
loiter extremely smart they're
self-motivated they're very hardworking
and you've got too much like a racehorse
you've got to make sure that you give
them the space to to develop and mature
and an accomplished so I think most of
my partner's would say the same thing I
mean it takes it takes an element of
defining the ultimate destination and
then empowering people to actually go to
achieve it you never make it by yourself
you always need others to help you I'm
good at what I do I'm really really good
at MA I'm not saying this with any level
of arrogance the only reason why I'm
saying that is I've put in over 25 years
perfecting the craft but the reason one
of the reasons why I'm good is that a
partner out of the Dallas office took me
under his wing and he said let me
apprentice you let me show you how to
become good at it he didn't say it in
exactly those words but in retrospect
that's what happened to me so mentorship
is incredibly important you want to be
successful at something you have to love
it and we're not fortunate enough that
we know off the bat that we love what we
do I didn't have a clue what I wanted to
be and I was in that bucket of
individuals that found myself in
something and then taught myself to love
it and so it becomes second nature to me
and you know I really like what I do and
I think that's another reason for
for being successful as you stay in the
consulting profession you've got to get
comfortable with being uncomfortable
mm-hmm it's a hen's a constant state of
flux on a my administrative assistant
kids meeow meeow on a daily basis my
schedule changes in terms of where I'm
going to be every week is a different
location and every project is very
different in terms of the dynamics which
you've got to achieve the people issues
and so at a certain point in time you
just become very comfortable with what
would be termed as stressful situations
as you go along on this journey remember
to stop and smell the roses for a little
bit frankly I didn't do enough of that I
wish I had I mean this is the funny
thing about life you realize you know
what I would love to do I spoke to a
number of students in India just a
couple of days ago and I said to them
they said what would you
in retrospect what would you like to do
I said what I'd like to be your age
which is 22 with the money I have now
and the knowledge I have now what life
is funny you know because you get the
money and you get the knowledge but life
has passed you by and so my response to
him is this is a journey and take some
time and smell the roses
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because any ket be asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next live in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of the top
10 rules meant the most to you leave it
in the comments and I'll join in
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and we'll
see you soon